i'm just waiting for the comment being
like no if only they did this with anime
i mean what anime channels do you guys
actually watch then like because i
watched john super eye patch yeah
i watched wolf i watched i want to shout
out beyond ghibli bjorn ghibli
does [ __ ] amazing anime videos um
and it's hard to describe
uh like like an anime youtube channel
right because that's what i do
yeah like how do i how do how do i
describe this anime youtube
channel basically he does amazing anime
analytical content
did a great one on hentai recently um
yeah i think check him out cartoon type
is pretty good i think they have a lot
of misses but when they hit they hit
good
yeah uh i gotta give a shout out to my
boy shaves like not sure
a lot of shapes like not gonna lie
sometimes i'm just looking forward to
being on his digest in the good section
honey okay tube digest which which is
which is a series
uh where shaves this uh this antituber
goes through basically like
some of like some of his favorite
youtube videos to do with like in the
anime youtube channel
his least favorite and some of his least
favorites as well and this is like the
one
series i pretty much think every anime
youtuber watches even though
even if they don't want to admit it i
told them like everyone watches
because everyone doesn't want to admit
it every attitude secretly
wants to be on the good side it's like
did i make it onto the good
one because the reason i like watching
it is because my taste in what makes a
good youtube or like what makes an
interesting youtube video
is so [ __ ] different yeah
that's what makes a good critic right
yeah you can just appreciate the cake
that he's doing and don't give a [ __ ]
about
if you disagree which is more often not
what i do don't worry shaves i'll do
more interview videos for you
i feel i feel like the worst thing you
can do as a critic is just flip-flop
right right if people know your
personality and people know what you
like
they don't give it doesn't really matter
if i disagree with your opinion right
i'm still going to watch
it anyway because i know what you like
and i take everything you
say with a grain of consistency yeah
that's what i respect about critics is
that like they're not afraid of the
backlash because
at the end of the day that is their
opinion right and it's like rather than
flip-flopping on your own words again
you just gotta double down you gotta
double down on europeans being like i
don't care
if the majority think that this is a
good video i don't think it's a good
video yeah these reasons you know
i've already i've already shouted out
scamboli reviews before yeah
i like uh he's called christian pants
he's talks a lot about uh lg tv oh yeah
and he's like he's just such a funny
person
he is his editing is kind of bad but
like man is he funny he's
so funny like he's just great he's just
brings such energy to [ __ ]
he doesn't
i would want to have a gossip session
with crispy nats yeah crispy nuts is
that what it's called
i think it's crispy i don't know but
when it comes to recommended i know that
like
the positivity is going to be there it's
so funny yeah it's so good well that's
really the only anime youtube channels i
watched unfortunately yeah
i mean you know we we basically just did
a [ __ ] two and a half hour long
recommendation awesome
just jump right into it yeah we jumped
right into today and awesome
i mean yeah i think i watch more anime
youtube channels but i don't okay i
don't subscribe to anyone but if it
appears in my feed
that normally means it's like a good
video that's worth watching because
like my my my subscription feed for
anime youtubers is just twitter
yeah basically yeah i'll sometimes watch
the best of the week that shape
recommends
and i'll be like god this is [ __ ]
awful
yeah i clearly have different tastes
yeah i mean i i respect his work
nonetheless
yeah i mean he did too ferris garden
lagon video i did watch the [ __ ]
two-hour thing it's [ __ ] long
yeah it's good i'll give him the man did
good voiceover was good exactly